[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hello, and
welcome to episode number 66
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Thanks Francesc.
I realize we still
have the same intro
where we say it's the weekly
"Google Cloud Platform
Podcast--"
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's a daily.
MARK MANDEL: --but it's a daily.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The daily weekly,
and the daily "Google Cloud
Platform Podcast" indeed.
MARK MANDEL: Indeed.
But soon we're back
to weekly, thank god.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh yes.
This is the third
episode in a row.
We released one on day
one of Google Cloud
Next, then day two.
This is on day three.
But we're going to be
covering everything
that happened during day
two, which was a lot.
MARK MANDEL: Which was a lot.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
a pretty intense day.
We're about to finish.
We're here on the ground floor.
So if you listen to this
episode, come say hi later.
And we have an
interview with a bunch--
we have actually a
bunch of interviews
with some of Google partners.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so we're going
to talk to a variety of partners
that we've literally plucked
from the show floor to come
to talk to us about what they
provide on top of our
services, but also how they
use our services and what
they're excited about for here
at Next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Most of them came
to be interviewed voluntarily.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Some of them.
MARK MANDEL: Some of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But yeah, we're
going to have a bunch of them.
But before that, I
thought that it was--
there's been so
many announcements
that I thought we should
mention just our favorites.
MARK MANDEL: Our favorites.
Yeah, so I'll go first, why not?
So if you remember back
in a previous episode,
we had a question of the
week where we actually went
through and said all the things
that you could use for free
on Google Cloud Platform.
So now there's
actually, first of all,
a dedicated page you can go
to, cloud.google.com/free.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: And it lists
out all the free tiers
that we have that are available.
Some of them are new.
Some of them are old.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Ooh.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so you can see
what it is you're able to
use for free on the platform.
Now that's not the only
thing which is cool.
So before, if you go
[INAUDIBLE] for a free trial,
it was $300 or 60 days.
You'd only hit the 60 days
well before you hit the $300.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, unless you're
doing really cool
stuff, which is fun.
MARK MANDEL: I know,
which is fine too.
But now it's $300 or 12 months.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
That is very good.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so
you have a whole year
to basically use Google
Cloud Platform with that
$300 if you're doing
like smaller stuff or dev
stuff, right, you've got a
whole bunch of time there to get
started and have a play.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
is pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: What about you?
What's your favorite thing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm going
to say that my favorite thing
also-- not necessarily
for me, because I've never
used Postgres, but for
so many people that
have asked this question
before is, that we do now
support PostgresSQL as a
managed database on Cloud SQL.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Which is amazing.
I mean, it is simple,
but basically now you
can create a managed instance.
So you get all the cool
things about being managed.
It will not go down.
We manage updates.
We manage security.
We manage patches.
We manage all the things.
So you just need to take
care about your data really.
So that is pretty amazing.
Very excited about.
Lots of people have been asking
for it for quite a while.
So we finally have it
and very happy with that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So why don't we go off and chat
with our friends at Tableau
and get started?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, let's go there.
MARK MANDEL: Joining us
on the Moscone floor,
we are joined today by
Martin Sleeman from Tableau.
Martin, how are you doing?
MARTIN SLEEMAN: Great.
Thanks how are you guys doing?
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Before we talk about
what like Tableau
and partners and
all that good stuff,
tell us a little bit
about who you are.
What do you do at Tableau?
MARTIN SLEEMAN: Sure.
My name's Martin, and I'm
a Tableau product manager,
for Tableau.
I worry about connectivity.
So I'm really interested
in all different types
of data sources,
especially Google ones.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So the only thing
I know is that one of the
data sources is BigQuery
and that Felipe Hoffa,
one of our teammates,
does really cool stuff with it.
But could you tell
us a little bit more
of what can you do with
Tableau given a BigQuery data
source, for instance?
MARTIN SLEEMAN: Oh
sure, absolutely.
Yeah, we do a lot
with Google BigQuery.
We've been integrated
with it for a long time.
It allows you to really see
and understand your data.
So you can do all
sorts of great stuff.
We have a demo we're going
to show this week that
using some of that public
New York taxi data,
which [INAUDIBLE] people about
what time are people getting
picked up the most, where
are they being picked up,
how many of these
disputes are happening,
and where are those
disputes occurring,
or when are those
disputes occurring?
So it's really
kind of cool to be
able to see this huge data set,
actually be able to understand
and get some
insights into it just
by looking at some great
visualizations that we can do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And you have a booth here today.
That demo, is it
going to be there,
or are you actually
having a session?
Are you speaking at
the conference too?
MARTIN SLEEMAN:
Yeah, great question.
We both have a booth,
and at the booth
you can actually see
the NYC taxi demo.
Should be great, lots of fun.
Also on Thursday, Vaidy,
one of my comrades,
will be actually doing a
presentation with Tim Swast
from Google itself.
It's called visualizing
big data on Google Cloud.
So we'll be part of
that, which is great.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
So if you're not physically
here, check out that recording.
That's really good.
Are you demoing
BigQuery at Tableau,
or Tableau and other things?
What are you actually
showing there?
MARTIN SLEEMAN: We'll be showing
just the general integration,
but we'll be focused
on Google BigQuery.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
And other than that session,
what other sessions are
you excited about?
MARTIN SLEEMAN: I'm
actually excited
about some of the other
big data sessions,
and also sort of how
to actually-- immersing
one about migrating data
into Google BigQuery, which
I was really excited about.
And I'm also kind of interested
about the machine learning
stuff, because I know
you guys are investing
a lot into machine learning.
And we'd love to see how
that's going to work out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Curious about it.
Today we had day one keynote.
And there was at the end a lot
of machine learning going on.
Could you have a comment on it?
Did you watch the keynote?
MARTIN SLEEMAN: Yeah,
I saw the keynote.
It was really cool.
The best part of
that, I thought,
was when she showed
the ability for them
to understand video now.
And so she put in a search
term basically saying beaches,
right?
And so it searched through
all of the video and found
you just the clips of beaches,
which I thought was fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was pretty amazing.
MARK MANDEL: So that was Sarah,
and she's one of our teammates.
And she's amazing.
MARTIN SLEEMAN: Yeah,
that was really cool.
That was great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
was a great demo, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, Martin, thanks so much for
coming and joining us and doing
a little interview with us.
And I hope you have a
really great Cloud Next.
MARTIN SLEEMAN: OK,
thanks very much.
It's been great.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again Martin
for joining us from Tableau,
super interesting conversation.
Visualizations are always
hugely, hugely important with--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They're really cool.
MARK MANDEL: --trying
to explain data.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, big
data without visualizations
is not really big data.
You want to be able to extract
things and show them to people
so they can understand
it very easily.
So Tableau, perfect
tool for that.
MARK MANDEL: So next up
we have Ed from Fastly
talking about really
cool stuff around CDNs
and basically trying
to get information
to people as fast as possible.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very Fastly.
MARK MANDEL: Very
Fastly, nice, I like it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
next in Cloud Next
we have Ed Bender from Fastly.
Hi Ed, how are you doing?
ED BENDER: I'm doing great.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Very good.
Very excited about
everything that is going on.
And also I want to
learn more about Fastly.
But why don't you tell us first
about what do you do at Fastly,
and then we'll talk
about what Fastly does.
ED BENDER: Sounds great.
So I'm on our strategic
partnerships team.
We work with a lot
of cloud companies,
as well as infrastructure as
a service ecosystem members.
We work globally.
We've got customers
all over the world.
And it's kind of
our job to make sure
that we're doing the right
things with the major origin
cloud providers in the world.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you work for Fastly.
What does Fastly do?
ED BENDER: Fastly
is an edge network.
It does edge delivery, edge
defense, edge data streaming,
edge compute.
Traditionally these
were known as CDNs.
And the space has
evolved quite a bit
to be handling a lot of
more interesting workloads
at the edge.
So we run the gamut of streaming
media, protecting sites,
and delivering dynamic assets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And I know that Fastly
and Google Cloud
Platform are pretty related.
Could you tell us a little bit
more about that relationship?
ED BENDER: Sure.
We've been a part of the
Google Next conference
series for three years,
since the first one.
And we've taken that globally
from Tokyo to Paris, New York,
and so on.
Our relationship with
Google originated
when we had a large customer
leaving a legacy CDN who needed
a place to store their assets.
We quickly identified Google
as being the preferred partner
for a storage solution.
And since then it's
evolved into handling
a number of integrations,
both from a network
standpoint, a product
standpoint, and a go to market.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And I think you're
talking about it specifically,
those topics, during one
of the sessions tomorrow, right?
ED BENDER: That's right.
Our CEO is speaking
tomorrow morning
as part of the storage track.
It's at 11:20 AM in room 2010.
His name's Artur Bergman.
And it's alongside the wonderful
product manager Kirill Tropin.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So yeah, if you're not
here, obviously you
can get the recording.
But while you're here, are you
excited about any announcements
that have come today, or maybe
any sessions that are coming up
in the next few days?
ED BENDER: I've
got to say I'm most
excited, at least
at first glance,
by the sheer volume
of this Next.
There's so many
people here, and it's
been amazing to kind of
ride alongside Google
for this whole past
few years as cloud
has become a larger and
larger part of the business.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We're definitely
growing, that's for sure.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's Moscone, right?
We're not messing around.
It's good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, thanks so much, Ed, for
taking the time to talk to us.
And have a great Next.
ED BENDER: Thank you so much.
Take care, guys.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
yeah, thanks, Ed,
for such an interesting
conversation.
Lots of cool stuff
going on at Fastly.
And next up we have Jonathan
Lieberman from Itopia.
And I got to say that when
we started talking to him,
I had no idea what they did.
And it is a very cool thing.
MARK MANDEL: It is
a very cool thing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so they
basically manage workspaces,
mostly Windows workspaces.
So you can imagine
like an office space.
So you can imagine all
of those workspaces being
migrated to the cloud.
And they run on
Google Cloud Platform.
So let's talk to
Jonathan Lieberman.
MARK MANDEL: So
we're joined today
by Jonathan Lieberman from
Itopia, a technology partner
with Google Cloud Platform.
Before we get into Itopia and
what it's all about, Jonathan,
why don't you tell
us a little bit
about what you do at Itopia?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Great.
Thank you.
So thank you for having me.
And I'm CEO and
co-founder of Itopia.
And we're really excited to
be here at Google Next '17,
where we just rolled
out and announced
our partnership with Google.
And we're really
excited to be here.
MARK MANDEL: So why don't you
tell us a little about what
Itopia does?
What's the whole
thing with Itopia?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: So
we build the technology
stack for IT service
providers, to make
it super easy for them to
move Windows workspaces
into the Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: OK,
so I'm a company.
Maybe I have a million desktops
or something like that.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Right.
MARK MANDEL: And then I went
to consolidate my resources
somehow.
Is that kind of the deal?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Right.
So that's a great use case.
And essentially what happens is
that you're facing end of life
on your server infrastructure.
You're evaluating your options.
Are you going to buy
and build something new,
or are you going to
move into a cloud?
And we're here to help you
move into the Google Cloud,
and essentially lift
and shift everything
that you have into the
Google Cloud, including
your servers, your desktops,
applications, data, everything
that you have right now
running your company.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So when you're
saying that you're
moving the desktops
and the workspaces,
does that mean that once you're
an employee of a company using
Itopia, whenever
you log in, you're
actually using some
remote desktop that
is running on our cloud?
Or how does that exactly work?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: That's
exactly how it happens.
So once we've migrated
the user into the cloud,
they'll access their
desktop from any device,
anywhere, any time
through an icon.
It might be a remote desktop.
Services could be
something else.
And it's a remote
user experience.
The user clicks on the icon.
And they're now on
their desktop running
their software and
processing and storage
through the Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: So, OK,
I'll ask the question.
Why did you choose Google Cloud?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: For us it
came down to three choices.
First of all, we looked at
everything in the market.
And at the end of
the day, Google
stood tallest when it came
to performance, price,
and your technology.
From a performance
standpoint, we
recognize and understand
that your Google Cloud
is the same thing that
runs G Suite, that
runs your search, that runs your
maps, everything, the lowest
latency in the market.
And for our service,
you need a low latency.
And so having data centers
throughout the world
is a very key differentiator
that we looked at.
From a price point of view,
you bill down to the minute,
compared with the others
that bill on an hourly basis.
And then from a
technology point of view,
everything that you're
doing, from machine learning
to AI to everything else, was
also very important to us,
as we want to deliver the
most innovative services
to our customers.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what does it entail to be
a partner with Google Cloud?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: So we went
through a very extreme vetting
process.
And you all looked
at our technology.
We connected with the team that
handles the types of use cases
and the types of
things that we do.
We worked with your engineers.
They kicked the tires.
And at the end of the day,
they came back with thumbs up
and invited us to be
part of your program.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So what does it mean now?
What are the kind of advantages
that you get as a partner?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN:
So we get to join
your ecosystem of
partners, from your G Suite
ecosystem to Chromebooks and
education, and in some cases
even large enterprises
that need help
and a technology stack to move
their clients into the cloud.
And that's why we're so
excited, because they
can partner with us to do that.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
All right, so we're here
at Cloud Next though.
What are you excited about?
What are you hearing
about or the sessions
you're going to that you think
are going to be really cool?
What's awesome for you?
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: A
little bit of everything.
Enjoyed the keynotes this
morning, Diane Greene.
Just sat through
the fireside chat
with Vint Cerf and
Marc Andreessen.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: And
that was super interesting.
And then also walking
the show floor,
we've been able to connect with
some of your premier partners.
We intend to be one
of them next year.
So i got to hear some
anecdotes about how to do that.
And really just being
here, able to network
with people that can use our
technology has been super.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much
for taking your time out
of, I'm guessing, a very
busy schedule here at Next.
It's been really great
having you come and join us
in the podcast booth.
And I hope you
have a great Next.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
JONATHAN LIEBERMAN:
Appreciate that.
MARK MANDEL: So cool.
I know you and I don't
do a lot with Windows,
but huge numbers of
people clearly do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So
thanks to Jonathan
for coming on the
podcast and having
a quick chat about Itopia.
Finally, last but
definitely not least, we
have James Williams
from Udacity talking
about Udacity, Google Cloud.
We've talked about it
about a bunch of times,
but still really
interesting, especially
if you want to learn
more about Google Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And I'm
very happy to have James
on the podcast for two reasons.
One is, I love Udacity.
They're really, really good.
And second, he's a
good friend of mine.
So let's talk to James.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
very happy to welcome
to the podcast one
of my dear friends,
James Williams from Udacity.
Hello, James.
How are you doing?
JAMES WILLIAMS: Hello.
I'm doing good.
MARK MANDEL: You
got dear friend.
I don't get dear friend.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You're just colleague.
You should be happy with
colleague at this point.
So why don't you
tell us a little bit
about what you do at Udacity?
JAMES WILLIAMS: All right,
I am a Android curriculum
lead at Udacity.
So I kind of shape and
guide the decisions
about what we should cover
and how we should cover
and stuff like that.
But I've also done some
web courses with Udacity.
Like, there was a
web tooling course
that I did with Paul Bakaus.
MARK MANDEL: So if
people don't know what
Udacity is, what is Udacity?
JAMES WILLIAMS: Udacity is
a online education company.
We have lots of free
and awesome courses.
We have a credential
called a Nanodegree that
allows people to
take courses, get
project reviews, mentor
feedback, and things like that.
And we have lots of free
courses with Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do
you have some courses
that you'd like to highlight,
especially related to cloud?
JAMES WILLIAMS: There is a
Kubernetes course with two
dudes who I cannot [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: Carter Morgan.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Kelsey
Hightower and Carter Morgan,
there you go.
JAMES WILLIAMS: Yeah, like the
really dapper-dressing dudes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's them.
JAMES WILLIAMS: So yeah, that's
probably the most related to
cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So since you're here
visiting Cloud Next,
what is the most
exciting session
for you out of the
next three days?
JAMES WILLIAMS: So do I
have to say your session?
MARK MANDEL: No you don't--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is totally fine.
MARK MANDEL:
--because everyone has
been saying Francesc's session.
You say my session.
It's fine.
JAMES WILLIAMS: So
I would say, it's
always fun to see
your friends present.
So I'm going to check
out Francesc's session.
Probably also Groovy product
lead Guillaume Laforge.
I'm going to check out
his session as well,
and try and get to
some of the stuff
on App Engine and
Google Cloud Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well thank you
so much for joining us here
at our little podcast space
at the floor of Moscone.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cloud
Next, Moscone West.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, thank
you for taking the time.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
have a good Cloud Next.
JAMES WILLIAMS: No worries.
Thanks, you guys, too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So thanks again.
Thanks so much to James
William from Udacity
for taking the time to talk
a little bit about what
they're up to on Udacity.
There's a lot of things
to check out from Udacity.
As we said, there's a very,
very good Kubernetes course
with our friends Kelsey
Hightower and Carter Morgan.
But on top of that, there's so
many other things to check out.
MARK MANDEL: Oh my god, so many
things to check out on Udacity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So as we said yesterday,
we had an episode where
we interviewed a bunch of
really cool people, one of them
Claire.
She calls herself--
MARK MANDEL: The czar of--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --the
czar of codelabs.
And she mentioned, all of
those codelabs are online.
So go check yesterday's episode
for a link to those codelabs.
And on top of that, there's
so many announcements.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So make sure, hope online.
A lot of the videos are
on YouTube right now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Actually yeah.
By the time this
episode comes out,
which will be some
sometime tomorrow morning--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
Friday morning.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, probably
our talks are already online.
So go check it out.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so absolutely.
There will be a link in the show
notes to the YouTube channel.
I know there will at least
be around 70 videos that
are available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
everything from day one
is there for sure.
From day two, most of
it will be by then.
So go check it out.
There's a lot of
things to learn.
And if you're
around, come say hi.
MARK MANDEL: Come say hi, yeah.
if you're here, come say hi.
We have stickers.
We have t-shirts.
We love talking to everyone
who's involved in the podcast.
So that's it, right?
Check out the podcast.
We've got daily episodes.
There's blog posts on
the Google Cloud blog.
There's YouTube videos,
the Udacity courses.
There's codelabs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You cannot be bored.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, there's
so much stuff to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So for
all of those that are here,
come say hi.
For all of those that are
far away from San Francisco,
go check all of
those resources out,
a bunch of links
in the show notes.
And no matter where you are,
talk to you all tomorrow.
MARK MANDEL: See you tomorrow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]